oh portfolios how much money and time
i've spent on getting my portfolio
printed
and reprinted and reprinted
for it to just sit on my shelf and look
pretty because most of the work
as soon as i printed is outdated an
online portfolio
is the exact opposite of that it's
flexible it's up to date and you can
customize it
and you're not limited to showing your
three to four
strongest projects like a pdf portfolio
and it's searchable if you're living in
the 21st century
an online portfolio by far is the best
way to show your work as an architect
also did you know that 70 of your
employers google you before setting up
an interview
if the first link is a direct link to
your website
you can control what they see
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dammy and i'm
a licensed architect
in beautiful vancouver bc on this
channel we talk about architecture and
design
and also some tools and strategies that
can help us have more meaningful
and fulfilling careers in architecture
this video is a continuation from my
last video where i walked through the
portfolio building process
i talked about what to include and what
not to include and
how to think about building it if you
haven't seen that video go check it out
before
diving into this one the pdf portfolio
is
great but it can be limiting in many
different ways
so today we're just gonna go over how
you can take the images you've selected
and put it online i'll be using wix who
is kindly sponsoring this video
um but i have to say i have tried
a lot of different website builders in
my life
um i started my first website when i was
like 16 years old
and wix by far is the most
intuitive and straightforward to use
i personally i really like it also i
just want to mention that this is a part
of a series i'm doing on the whole
job application process which is a very
very common question that i get
and so in this series i'm going to talk
about how to build your portfolio
how to write your resume and your cover
letter
how to put yourself online and the
benefits of having an online presence
and i'll also be talking about some
interview tips
and how you can talk about your work and
your experience
so today i'm going to be taking you
through step by step on how to create a
wix website using the images that you've
selected
all right so let's get right into it
so i already started building my website
and started playing around with one of
the layouts
but i'm just going to create a new one
just so that you guys can see so
create a new site
and there is an option to do the
portfolio
and cv um and
you can let the wix adi create a website
for you
or which is basically um
you answer a bunch of questions and they
make a website
for you based on those answers um or
you can create your own website with the
editor
and um i tried this one i didn't like
this one as much
i didn't really like what they created
for me
so i opted for this one and there's like
so many great templates to choose from
and um the customization process
is like so straightforward that i think
um
i imagine that you guys are all quite
picky about
the way things look so i would highly
recommend
customizing your own website based on
the templates
um so for me
i wanted to use a template where
like something like this is really nice
because you have your
cover page as soon as you
enter the site so um yeah you can look
at the demos of the
templates here
and you can click through the project
or there's options where you go into the
site
and you have information about you
and a photo that's also nice and
personal
but what i wanted was something more
like this
where you can go into your link
and right away you see
the graphics of your project
so
yeah something like this is quite nice
actually
the one that i ended up selecting
is this one
[Music]
so let's go ahead
and edit this site and i'll show you how
that works
okay so you have your main page and
i i'm assuming you'll have your work
page
you'll have your info page and this
could be like
your blog or if you have um any social
media channels you can link it here
um so i'll probably
change that to
blog done
but this is
the page where we'll be spending the
majority of our time
the way it works is this is just
a list of images
go to manage media and you'll see all
the images that are on this page
and each image is linked to
another page that you will populate
um so we'll just go ahead and populate
the
pages first so you go into this column
and you go under work and those are all
the pages
that you see so what i'm gonna do is
i'm just gonna go in and
basically like replace these images with
my portfolio images so i'm gonna
delete these and
add my own media
[Music]
okay and if you want to keep these
images organized because once you
upload the media it's all going to get
populated in this folder
so you can actually um create a new
folder
and just like you would on your computer
you just create a folder for your
project
so
other website building platforms
move to anthropocene folder perfect
so now we can keep it nice and organized
and like that's literally it that's
literally all i have to do
and it's populated all of my images and
if i want to reorder them
just go to manage media and
it's gonna be like
this
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so that's
an option if you want to include
all the images all at the same time but
let's say you want to
have it so that this image is actually
the main image and you want this to be a
lot bigger than any of the other images
you just go here add and add
image my uploads i've already uploaded
these photos
so you can go in here um
let's say you want this to be the main
that's gonna be like
your money shot maybe so you put that
here you just drag this down
and bring it here
yeah the images will um snap in place
so let's say you want to have it left
justified or you want to have it
centered
it'll just snap it in place
you see that
and um
i've saved all of my
text for the images
uh here and i would
suggest maybe doing that to sort of
streamline the process
just select all the text for your
projects
in a document so that you can easily
come in and just plop and
plop in the information
hmm
i i typically add um just the
project information what studio or what
year
i made that project in
and so this text is
a text template it's very similar to
how you would use indesign so if you
know in design this is going to be like
a piece of cake for you
um so this is in the style of paragraph
two and having these paragraph styles is
great
so that you can keep a consistent font
throughout
all of your pages so let's say
i want to actually not use avenir lights
but use barlow medium
right so if you just change it in here
it's only going to change it within this
page
you're not going to change the parameter
of paragraph
2. so if you want this barlow medium to
be applied on
all of the pages throughout the website
you have to
not change it in here but change the
parameter
of paragraph two so you go here
go to edit theme and
paragraph two and you change it
in here barlow extra light apply
and it'll apply to this page
and all of the pages where you use this
text
as paragraph 2.
and let's say you used a different
font different unique font for this
particular page
you click into it and
okay and it'll tell you like it'll tell
you
you're using paragraph two but what that
little star means
is that you've modified the um
like the base parameter of paragraph two
okay i hope i didn't really like belabor
that point too much
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um and the other great thing about
wix is that you can add the captions
directly on the pages so you go here
add text um
and typically what i've done um with
other website builders is i would
um basically like export the images
with the captions and the text because
i was never able to get the layout to a
point where
the pictures and the captions were like
arranged
in the way that i want um
but because all of this like basically
what you see is what
you get like you just move things around
and you can change the font and the size
of the font
and that's basically what's
gonna show up
so i really like that
can add pretty much anything in here
you can add your social media icons here
that looks a little uh spammy
but uh you can do that you can
go in and get rid of all of these
and you know what let's say i want to
add my youtube
icon on here right i'm gonna add this to
the gallery
and i'm gonna create a link to that icon
okay
and let's preview this
so click on this
it's going to lead my directory when i
was good
yeah it's going to lead me directly to
that site so
that's really great and you can
basically do that
with any of the images so let's say i
want to create a link
to this image then i can just put in the
url here
and it'll just leave me directly to that
page
and let's say i want to change the
background
of just this page to black um
you can do that by going here change
background and um
color
obviously if you do this you're going to
have to go in and
change the font colors and everything to
white so that you can see that
okay
there's also an option to display your
instagram feed
so just add the widget here
and okay i don't want to show this on
this page
i think i probably want to show it
on the maybe the info page
so i'll go to
social and
oh no that's not it
go to add apps and
instagram feed
again and there it is
there's your instagram feed
so that does mean that i have to shift
all of this down
oh i freaking love it you can just drag
and drop
so here you can connect this to your
instagram
[Music]
there we go there's my instagram feed
amazing let's preview this
[Music]
okay so
i'm just gonna go to my other site that
i've already
sort of added a couple of um
portfolio items on okay so i've already
added three projects on the site
and um now
[Music]
can do that
what i'm doing now is i'm just
populating this
all of these pages with the names of my
project
so that i can just go in and plop in the
images and the text
okay there we go so i have the list of
my projects
and now i just have to go in and
populate them
okay so you can see that i've already
uploaded some of the images
um but i have not saved them into
folders
[Music]
so
create a new folder
move here
do
[Music]
[Music]
i don't remember which year i did this
in honestly
i think it was 2 2016.
and you'll also have instances where
like let's say you brought
all of these images in um and you're
just
trying to set some sort of a hierarchy
maybe you're
playing around with the layout maybe you
want some images
to read more importantly so
you're doing that and just moving things
around
and then you decide uh actually i
actually kind of want them to be all the
same
size so you click through this
and you say um make everything
the same width and it'll automatically
do that for you you can also
evenly distribute
so there's equal spacing between all of
the images
and you can do that vertically as well
so let's say you had um
you have three different images
and you wanted them to be spaced equal
distance apart then you just go
here oops oopsies
you just go here
and do this it'll move
but for now i just want them all to be
the same
oh you can also align everything to the
middle you can align everything
to the left you can justify everything
to the right
you can move all the images to the
bottom
you know okay yeah you can also group
these elements
which means that you move one of them
and moves all of them together
so i really like that
let's give them equal equal spacing
and make it all the same width perfect
okay and so
you just save it so once you've
populated
all of these images you go to your
main work page and i've
uh i've already sort of done this but
you click on this and you do
manage media which is basically going to
control
all the images that show up in this
front page
so you go in and you add
thumbnails of the projects that you want
to show
i've just created a folder for all the
projects that i want to show so that i
can easily just go into the folders and
pull out the images that i want
and i actually already did this when i
was building my
pdf portfolio so it's easy to just move
it into the website
typically what you want to do is you
want to reduce the size of these images
so that they load faster on your website
so try to keep it to like a maximum of
500 megabytes
without like losing the quality of the
images once you have the thumbnail
uploaded you can change the
title
and um
[Music]
[Music]
and for long images like this you just
want to go in
and put a focus here so that if you have
a square
thumbnail it's going gonna only crop out
the
two sides and still show the middle
once you have that image in you wanna
just link it
to that page that you created so
border crossing done
cj
page
done
so now you have this list of um
thumbnails on your front page and if you
want you can go to
layout and just play around with how you
want that to be shown
so right now i have this grid but maybe
i want something
that's a little bit less regular
yeah this collage is kind of interesting
because
i don't really have consistency
in the thumbnails themselves like i have
renders
i have physical models i have
photographs of the finished work so i
think
collage might be good so you go to the
layout and if you want to change around
how that looks you go to
um you go to um customize layout
and you can change the thumbnail size
so it can be a lot smaller you can
change the
spacing of the images as well
um collage density
[Music]
move around how that looks
[Music]
so this is what it looks like when you
hover over the image with your mouse so
that's what it looks like without the
hover that's what it looks like with the
hover
so you can also change how that looks
um
so you can change the font of the title
as well
um right now i'm using heading 4.
remember i told you
if you want to change the text globally
you change it within
the headings and the paragraphs and if
you want to
change it just the instance then you go
and change the font
[Music]
[Music]
so i'm doing this but if i
see that i actually didn't set up any
fonts
in the paragraph or the heading styles
that i want to use here
you can just go in here and change
the font independently so this isn't
going to make any changes
to the presets that i i've already set
up for the paragraphs and the headings
it's going to um only change it
for the fonts for the title fonts on
this page
and here i don't want to
show a store probably i'll have my
blog
and info um that will be my personal
[Music]
info
that does kind of doesn't look like me
so i'll put in my image here
there's also a huge selection of images
that you can use from
wix um but if you
are an architect i'm assuming that you
would want to put in your own images
but
and you can also select your images from
instagram so i'm gonna do that
yeah i like that
and here you can put in your um cv and
your resume
which i will be covering in my next
video
and
for the blog you can start a blog
yes blog independently
get started and let's see manager
blog pages create a post
okay i'm just gonna publish
i haven't actually published the site
yet but
on the blog post you can definitely
modify the text
and you can add your own images
ah okay never mind i was wrong i
should not have created i should not
have turned
this into a blog because once you create
the blog it automatically gets added
into
the um the menu so i can just delete
this
um and
let's see what it looks like
that's like a pretty nice
website for literally like 10 minutes of
work
it also gives me a view of what the page
will look like in mobile view
you can customize how the header looks
so you can do a scroll with a page
or you can make the header disappear
which is
yeah i kind of like that or it can fade
in or out
i'm gonna make it disappear nice and
minimal
and here you can position like your
phone number your email or your facebook
yeah and back to the
top button do i want that no
i don't think i want that and check out
what else i can do
for the mobile editor so you can
actually
very nicely customize what it looks like
on mobile so if
i
wanted to
okay
so if i wanted to i can change the
layout just for the mobile
version as well so i've set it up on a
masonry view
on the website view but on the mobile i
can change it to a grid view
and yeah you can change the
ratio of the images
see how many images you want to show per
row
spacing white space is always good
there we go
save your changes okay
go back to the site
on the mobile view
let's see what this looks like
so that's what's going to look like on
the phone
so that's basically it guys uh you can
build
a fully functioning website within like
20 minutes
um as long as you have your projects and
your images and your text already
planned out
i would highly highly highly recommend
having a website
or some sort of an online platform that
hosts all of your work
i think you should just get into the
mindset and habit of like showing your
work to the world
um it's a little bit of extra work of
course
but i think it really pays off dividends
in the long run
um especially if you're applying for
jobs
i would also highly recommend using wix
um
i would actually never recommend
something that i didn't love using
myself
and um like i said i've used so many
different website builders in my life
and this is by far the most intuitive
and the least frustrating and
it's just great for people who want to
have a
high level of visual customization
and don't want to spend a lot of time on
it
so if you're interested follow my link
in the description
and you can get access to the free
version um
and actually with the free version you
can basically get a fully functioning
website that can host all of your
projects
so i hope you guys found this helpful
and uh this should be a fun
and exciting process so uh good luck and
have fun
and let me know if you have any
questions in the comments
see you in the next video bye
[Music]